vous avez toujours cru que c'était votre
meilleur ami et bien non pas du tout en
course à pied
la descente elle est méchante bonjour
les amis runner et oui la descente elle
est méchante en course à pied
tout simplement parce que c'est
certainement là avec les codes bien sûr
mais que les cuisses souffrent le plus
pourquoi ça et bien parce que vous avez
l'impression de vous reposer mais en
fait vous puissiez se repose pas du tout
vous mettez naturellement en position
arrière et l'avocat puisse se raidissent
tout le travail tout votre poids porte
sur vos muscles à l'avant des cuisses et
je vous prie croire que si la descente
et longue demain matin vous allez vous
en souvenir donc quelques conseils pour
négocier correctement négocier une
descente
et bien c'est comme à ce qui faut pas se
mettre trop en avant pas trop en arrière
pour essayer d'avoir un juste équilibre
trouvé un milieu ralentir sa course bien
sûr essayer d'être le plus souple
possible pour alléger sa foulée ça
paraît facile à dire comme ça mais en
tout cas essayer de faire parce que ça
va considérablement soulagé votre foulée
et vos cuisses alors c'est un travail
répétitif pour bout de plusieurs séances
vous aurez moins de couleurs mais si
vous pouvez éviter les descentes c'est
comme les côtes
c'est pas plus mal parce que pour les
débutants ça peut être problématique
une prochaine pour des conseils en ligne